الصحي في درنا الحقيقه بدا يتعافى يعني
هناك مستشفيات ميدانيه موجوده كل الخدمات
الصحيه يتم تقديمها للمواطنين
بايجاز من غرفه
اخبار اهلا بكم عمليات البحث عن مفقودين
وانتشار الجثث تستمر في دارنا شرقيه ليبيا
ووزاره الصحه بالحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان تعلن بدء التعافي بالمدينه
المنقوبه وان الوضع فيها مستقر والصاجود
عالميه للتخفيف من وطاه الكارثه بينما
تؤكد منظمه الهجره الدوليه نزوح اكثر من
43 الف شخص بسبب فيضانات بعد نحو اسبوعين
من وقوعي زلزال عمليه ايواء الناجين في
المغرب تتسارع بينما تواصل فرق الانقاذ
والاغاثه عملياتها والديوان الملكي
المغربي يعلن تخصيص 12 مليار دولار لاعاده
اعمار المناطق المنكوبه على مدى خمس سنوات
ضمن برنامج يستهدف نحو اربعه ملايين ومئتي
الفين سماء ارمن اقليم كاراباخ والسلطات
الاذربيجانيه ينهون جوله المباحثات بشان
حل الصراع في الاقليم دون الاعلان عن
نتائجها مستشاروا زعيم الاقليم يتهم روسيا
والغرب وارمينيا بالتخلي عن مواطني
الاقليم وبوتين يشدد على اهميه حمايه
الارمن هناك في حين تظاهر الالاف في
ارمينيا احتجاجا على اداره الحكومه للازمه
في كهرباء
البرلمان السويسري يقر قانونا يحضر تغطيه
الوجه بطريقه لا تسمح بالتعرف على ملامحه
في الاماكن العامه والخاصه التي يمكن
لعامه الناس الوصول اليها ويواجه
المخالفون غرامه تصل الى ما يقارب الفن
ومئه دولار بينما رفضت طلبات المقدمه من
البرلمانيين لاجراء تغييرات في الصياغه
والغرامات والاعفاء
الى اللقاء